peu
[Musique]
et
bonsoir
eh bien vous présenter un nouveau jeu
représente toujours pour nous une
aventure en effet malgré les répétitions
les mises au point que nous pouvons
faire avant le premier passage d'antenne
est bien dans une émission de jeu jamais
le climat réel de l'émission et obtenu
aussi ce soir c'est à une vraie première
que ne vous invite chaque semaine pas
une seconde à perdre donnera l'occasion
à deux concurrents de surmonter chacun
quatre épreuves dans la spécialité
qu'ils ont choisi et ses spécialités
sont au nombre de quatre on peut se
présenter a pas une seconde à perdre en
arts et lettres en sciences et
découvertes en histoire et en notre
temps notre temps couvrant la période
contemporaine depuis l'invention du
cinématographe chacune des épreuves les
quatre épreuves par semaine amène 9
réponses possibles et première
difficulté notre jeu le concurrent est
éliminé si en première semaine
il ne donne pas 4 réponses justes sur
les neuf possibles en deuxième semaine 5
sur 9 puis 6 sur 9 ans 3e set sur 9 ans
4e 8 sur 9 ans 5e seul autre chose de
très important c'est le temps pas une
seconde à perdre oui pour surmonter les
quatre épreuves chaque semaine
le concurrent dispose d'un total de 200
second il en dispose comme il le désire
il peut utiliser par exemple je ne sais
pas moi 65 secondes pour une épreuve et
puis 80 pour une haute et 35 seulement
pour la suivante
à l'issue de la cinquième et dernière
semaine
le concurrent ayant surmonté toutes nos
épreuves pourra gagner au minimum 45
mille francs c'est à dire 4 million et
demi d'enfants et au maximum cinquante
cinq mille francs 5 million et demi de
nos anciens il est donc que les enjeux
sont importants
la progression des gains est la suivante
50 francs par raiponce en première
semaine puis s'emparent réponse en
deuxième 200 pas répond 103e 404e et 500
francs par raiponce en dernière semaine
le concurrent ne peut abandonner qu'une
seule fois dans notre jeu il n'a qu'une
porte de sortie en quelque sorte à la
fin de la quatrième semaine à partir de
la deuxième semaine vous téléspectateurs
vous pourrez venir en aide aux
concurrents comment est bien en devenant
supporters de ce concurrent pour cela à
la fin de cette émission je vous
préciserai les conditions nécessaires à
remplir mais dès maintenant sachez qu'il
faudra nous envoyer une carte postale
sur laquelle vous marquerez bien sûr
votre nom et votre adresse votre numéro
de téléphone qui devra obligatoirement
être appelée de paris parle automatique
c'est une petite réception mais nous
sommes obligés de la faire
et enfin bien sûr ce secteur postal vous
indiquerai la spécialité pour laquelle
vous sentez le mieux armé le plus fort
toutes ces cartes classés par ordre bien
entendu seront à la disposition du
concurrent à partir de la deuxième
semaine et par quatre fois au cours des
semaines suivantes
il pourra faire appel aux supporteurs
pour l'aider à répondre à une question
et ses supporteurs seront intéressés à
5% du gain final de concurrents voyez
donc que vous qui êtes dans votre
fauteuil actuellement dans votre
télévision bien mon dieu vous pourrez
aussi participer à distance a pas une
seconde à perdre voilà je crois qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de vous donner de
plus amples explications pour l'instant
il était nécessaire par contre vous
donner quelques unes que je viens de
vous dire c'est toujours un petit peu le
pensum jeu c'est le chien pendant une
première émission de jeu mais on ne peut
pas commencer l'émission sans
explication et bien maintenant
voici notre premier concurrent
[Musique]
il
monsieur vous vous nommer jean pierre
castaing vous avez 25 ans vous êtes
ingénieur ingénieurs de quelle école
monsieur je suis sorti de l'école
centrale il ya deux ans sortait des
chorales de deux ans il est marié
monsieur suis marié et père de famille
père de famille combien d'enfants un
seul à ça quelles sont les raisons qui
vous ont incité à participer à notre jeu
me suis testé c'est un petit peu par
curiosité plus connus pour voir comment
ça se passait de l'autre côté de l'écran
de l'autre côté de l'écran vous avez
déjà été tenté de participer à des jeux
par curiosité on ne l'est pas encore eu
l'occasion mais n'avait jamais fait bien
dans cette très très vaste catégorie que
représente science et découverte puisque
c'est la spécialité dans laquelle vous
présenter quels sont justement les
matières sur lesquelles vous sentez le
mieux armé le plus fort je me suis
aperçu que j'ignorais beaucoup de choses
mais je crois que j'en ignore encore
beaucoup plus en sciences naturelles
quand technique donc les sciences
naturelles pour vous ce n'est pas la
partie forte seine-et-marne et bien et
bien mon dieu vous aurez un peu de tout
et je devrais le déchirent pour cette
première semaine mais vous n'avez que 4
répond juste sur neuf je le rappelle a
donné il y aura pas mal de sciences
naturelles
enfin nous pouvons penser à la première
épreuve bien sûr bien sûr alors
regardons le
[Musique]
monsieur vous allez voir apparaître
successivement 9 invention célèbre et
vous allez devoir nous dire par oui ou
par non vix est extrêmement simple pour
cette première épreuve
vous allez devoir nous dira si buffon de
son vivant a pu connaître ces inventions
voyez c'est vous même monsieur qui
commandait le passage de chaque vue qui
vont présenter à vous au moyen du bouton
qui est à votre main droite
le chronomètre commencera à décompter
les secondes dès l'apparition de la
première image je signale à nos
téléspectateurs que ce chronomètre qui
décomptent donc le capital tant que vous
avez 200 secondes
le décompte de deux secondes en deux
secondes bien voilà monsieur nous sommes
maintenant au départ et vous avez à
votre disposition
le petit bouton qui vous déclencherez
vue vous pouvez partir quand vous le
désirez je rappelle buffon aurait-il pu
connaître ses inventions
le fardier de cugnot on ne répondait pas
oui si oui à part d'un vaccin
antivariolique non non montgolfier
l'expérience
oui oui métiers à tisser jacquard non
non gaz d'éclairage
oui machine à écrire non machine à
calculer
oui paratonnerre oui télégraphe de
chappe
non non au monsieur vous avez été très
vite très très vite le chrono s'il vous
plaît l'arrêt du chrono s'il vous plaît
merci vous voulez remonter à 162
secondes pour le chrono vous avez mangé
quatre secondes à monsieur castres il
n'a pas besoin qu'on lui père john 162
s'il vous plaît bien
monsieur pendant qu'on remet notre
chrono en place je voudrais vous poser
une question est ce que vous croyez que
vous êtes dans dans les temps comme vous
pourrez dire en sport vous croyez avoir
donner quatre réponses justes sur 9,4
certainement 4 certainement
et même peut-être un peu plus tôt plus
vous avez été très vite 38 secondes
seulement pour cette épreuve messieurs
et vous disposez d'une moyenne de 50
puisque 200 secondes pour quatre
épreuves vous fait une moyenne de 5 ans
voyons les résultats monsieur les voici
le fardier de cugnot vous avez répondu
oui vous avez raison il fut inventé en
1771 et buffon est mort en 1788 donc il
a pu le connaître
ensuite monsieur le vaccin
antivariolique vous avez répondu non et
là vous avez raison en effet il fut
inventé en 1798
après la mort de buffon enfin
l'expérience de montgolfières numéro 3
vous avez dit oui il aurait pu connaître
vous avez raison
cette expérience eu lieu près exactement
cinq ans avant sa mort en 1783 métiers à
tisser jacquard vous avez dit non et
vous avez raison car ce métier ne
fermente etc en 1805 le gaz d'éclairage
vous avez répondu oui et vous avez
encore raison car il fut inventé en 1785
trois ans avant la mort de buffon pour
la machine à écrire là vous avez tort
monsieur la machine à écrire fut
inventée en 1714 voyez-vous est là donc
c'est une mauvaise réponse
la première ensuite vous avez dit pour
la machine à calculer bien sûr c'est
pascal vous en doutiez monsieur oui bien
entendu 752 le paratonnerre qui vient en
huitième position
vous avez dit encore oui et vous avez
raison il fut inventé en 1752
vous avez par contre refusé le
télégraphe chappe et vous avez eu raison
en effet il fut inventé en 1794 donc
après la mort de buffon en 1788 monsieur
très très bonne première réponse puisque
vous totalisé 8 sur 9 et un gain de 400
francs 5,8 x 50 francs donc pour
l'instant 400 francs à votre talent de
gamme monsieur sa part bien mais ça
c'était dans les techniques c'était dans
votre branche
nous allons maintenant passer à la à la
géographie et dirons nous une géographie
mais les un peu de météorologie monsieur
est ce que cette discipline vous si
aussi bien que la précédente
un peu moins bien un peu moins alors
regardons là
[Musique]
eh bien monsieur cette valse de chiffres
vous avez pensé sans doute au fuseau
horaire bien sûr et cette question va
porter sur les fuseaux horaires notre
maquettiste de michel et nick a
symbolisé ici monsieur neuf clochers
situées dans 9 villes du monde chacune
des horloges que vous avez devant vous
sont à midi pour l'instant nous allons
supposé monsieur qui les héros heures à
paris bien sûr l'heure en temps
universel c'est à dire que nous ne
tenons pas compte de certains décalages
horaires qui sont la pratique de
certains pays nous parlons la
scientifique
donc il s'agit bien sûr de leurs
universel donc les erreurs à paris en
temps universel et vous allez devoir
monsieur bien sûr nous dire quelle heure
il est dans ses neuf villes ces heurts
vous les avez à votre disposition
elles vont maintenant apparaître sur
votre écran les voici
voici les neuf heures que vous avez à
replacer
n'est ce pas en tournant le cadran de
chaque horloge de ces petites de ces
petites églises que vous avez devant
vous avez compris la question du lieu
oui je trouve ça va alors monsieur bien
sûr il vous reste 160 de seconde pour
trois épreuves vous avez 9h à placer il
est zéro heure à paris en temps
universel
quelle heure est il dans ces neuf villes
chrono
[Musique]
tellement
que s'en prendre
d
vous avez encore des tensions êtes dans
votre moyenne pour l'instant
100 secondes continuer s'il vous plaît
le chrono s'est arrêté à 100 s'il vous
plaît vous continuez de grenache que
monsieur vous avez bénéficié de deux
secondes de plus je parle que notre
chrono a fait un petit peu de retard sur
vous ne seront pas très méchant cette
première semaine pour l'instant vous
avez placé maintenant vos heures sur les
horloges évidemment question très
difficile
et bien sûr vous n'êtes pas très très
sûr de vos réponses
monsieur est ce que je vois vous avez
beaucoup hésité nous allons maintenant
si vous le voulez bien regarder les
résultats puisqu'il n'est pas question
aujourd'hui de faire appel à supporter
attention voici votre première réponse
pour tananarive vous avez dit 21h
monsieur pas du tout quand ils les
erreurs à paris il est 3 heures à tana
beyrouth vous n'avez vous avez mis zéro
heure je suppose mission en fait je sais
que de questions et réponses sont
fausses parce que j'ai inversé toutes
les aires le sens de la marche au soleil
c'est un petit peu ennuyeux à beyrouth
il était 2h monsieur ensuite à mexico
vous avez dit qu il était 19h vous êtes
plus près là ils étaient 17 ensuite à
londres vous avez dit 0 24 heures c'est
votre première bonne réponse
ensuite monsieur à rio vous avez dit qu
il était 3h du matin non il est 21h
monsieur les neuf heures du soir
ensuite monsieur vous avez dit à
saint-louis louisiane mais vous n'avez
rien dit n'ai pas mis de réponse non
plus à melbourne monsieur vous n'avez
que donnait que deux heures alors que il
est 10 heures du matin à montréal
vous n'avez rien me et à saint denis de
la réunion
vous n'avez vous avez dit monsieur je ne
vois pas l'heure s'ils veulent une heure
mais c'était faux vous avez fait la même
erreur oui je vois vous avez mis huit
heures monsieur je suis navré c'est un
jeu très difficiles nouveaux
téléspectateurs peuvent se rendre compte
dès le premier concurrent car en effet
vous perdez dès la deuxième épreuve
monsieur vous n'avez pas rempli votre
contrat vous n'avez pas les quatre
bonnes réponses
sur neuf qui sont obligatoires c'est ce
qu est un je suis navré il est normal
d'ailleurs que vous ayez quelques
difficultés car mon dieu vous êtes le
premier concurrent d'un jeu c'était très
difficile pour vous puisque vous n'aviez
jamais vu avant évidemment vous aviez à
la fois les difficultés d'une première
n'est ce pas et le trac qui s'empare
automatiquement d'un concurrent
lorsqu'il vient pour la première fois la
télévision
monsieur certainement dans quelques
temps nous pourrons peut-être vous
donner une autre chance mais
malheureusement ce soir vous avez perdu
monsieur castaing je suis désolé nous
allons maintenant passer à la seconde
concurrentes qui maintenant va se
présenter devant tu vois si cette
seconde pointures
[Musique]
mademoiselle vous nommez mademoiselle
reynès vous avez 20 ans oui vous êtes
étudiante
oui qu'étudier vous le russe pour
l'instant et l'allemand cette année nous
attendons orientale en effet quelle
profession envisagez-vous d'exercer bien
je n'envisage rien de très précis pour
l'instant rien de très précis pour
l'instant bien dans la discipline que
vous avez choisie c'est-à-dire arts et
lettres est tout à fait à l'opposé de la
précédente puisque monsieur gaston mais
choisit sentier découverte dans cette
discipline quels sont vos points forts
mademoiselle bien je crois pouvoir
compter sur la littérature et peut-être
aussi sur la peinture la peinture donc
faiblesse côté musique par exemple tu
peux avoir l'effet escompté musique oui
ouvert va des faiblesses côté je vous
posais cette question car voyez vous
décidez pas de chance mais la première
épreuve de ce soir sera musicale
alors si vous voulez bien mademoiselle
200 secondes au départ vous le savez
quatre épreuves à surmonter quatre
bonnes réponses sur neuf obligatoires
nous voyons cette première épreuve
des mains de virtuoses celle de franz
liszt
ah non pardon ce sens elle de chopin
mais nous pouvions nous y trompez celle
de liszt les voici les pianos eux mêmes
s'y tromper bien souvent les dames et
cela prêtait à confusion surtout en
matière de fugueurs est toutefois pour
un amateur éclairé il demeure confondant
de les confondre
[Musique]
et bien mademoiselle
nous avons invité dans notre studio
monsieur tasso janot boulot et madame
brugeron les plaisir de les accueillir
je madame bonjour monsieur ils vont nous
interpréter neuf extraits des oeuvres
pour piano de chopin et liszt
vous devez mademoiselle à chaque fois
identifié le compositeur en me disant
simplement chopin ou liste vous arrêter
ainsi le morceau en cours et nous
passons au suivant c'est simple comme
mécanisme ce n'est pas forcément simple
pour répondre à cet événement dont vous
le savez 4 identification juste au moins
sur les neuf possibles
vous n'êtes pas être posée on peut
essayer
bon alors attention monsieur dassault
jeunes au boulot
le premier morceau et chrono en même
temps
chapin
oh
les pistes
chopin shop vous ne savez pas ce top
[Musique]
chopin
ne répondez pas mademoiselle de tenter
une réponse ça me fait rien à tenter une
réponse
chopin
[Musique]
mais tente une réponse la demoiselle ne
me dit pas je sais pas liste
je peins chopin
chopin pape aubade moselle que vous avez
des difficultés effectivement dans la
musique
eh bien nous allons voir les résultats
si vous le voulez bien vous avez utilisé
82 secondes pour cette première épreuve
résultat s'il vous plaît en numéro 1
vous avez dit shop et vous avez raison
mademoiselle il s'agissait bien de
chopin en numéro 2 vous avez dit liste
vous avez encore raison il s'agissait
bien de liste en numéro 3 vous avez dit
chopin non il s'agissait de listes
mademoiselle en numéro 4 vous n'avez
rien dit vous avez eu tort c'était
chopin en numéro 5 vous avez dit chopin
il s'agissait de listes mademoiselle en
numéro 6 vous avez dit chopin et vous
avez raison il s'agit bien de chopin en
numéro 7 vous avez des listes il
s'agissait de chopin la demoiselle en
numéro 8
vous avez dit shop il s'agissait de
listes donc attention
la dernière réponse va décider de tout
car si vous avez bien répondu vous aurez
des 4 nécessaires sinon où serait
éliminé dès le départ
voici cette dernière réponse regardons
la en neuvième position
vous avez dit shah pas et c'est bon
mademoiselle c'est ben oui faut dire que
c'était peut-être le plus facile des
morceaux identifie oui sans aucun ellien
dites moi c'est juste juste quatre
réponses justes 4 demandé 200 francs
pour cette première épreuve moselle nous
avons frôlé dès le départ la catastrophe
également là le trac joue beaucoup je
sais très très très difficile
mademoiselle la peinture ça va un peu
mieux
peut-être peut-être mieux ta musique de
toute façon il vous sera alors regardons
la deuxième épreuve
c'était le 2 décembre 1804 et pour la
deuxième fois de notre histoire
un souverain et des couronnes et à notre
dame le premier s'appelait henry 6
c'était un enfant et il était angles le
second se nomme et napoléon 1er il était
dans sa 36ème année et il est et corse
il était là d'être césar il devenait
charlemagne le faste de son couronnement
fut tel qu'il demeure gravée dans toutes
les mémoires
cet ancien lieutenant d'artillerie
réunissez dans les pompes de son sacre
la solennité capétienne et la grandeur
rohmer demoiselle nous allons bien sûr
parler vous en doutez d'un tableau très
célèbre très classique qu'est le sacre
de l'empereur david vous savez que dans
ce tableau du sacre david a donné un
véritable portrait de chacun des
participants bien vous allez voir
maintenant neuf personnages extraits de
deux toiles de david les uns proviennent
bien sûr du sacre d'autres de l'autre
toile qui n'est pas ça à vous de rendre
au sacre ce qui appartient au sacre donc
je vous avais faire défiler neuf
extraits de tableau quand vous
considérez que c'est le sac vous me
répondez oui quand vous considérez que
ce n'est pas le sacre vous répondent ils
les vues c'est une question où vous
pouvez aller un peu plus vite que dans
la précédente sans aucun doute vous
pouvez donc gagné un petit peu de temps
pour l'instant votre moyenne des
mauvaises puisque vous n'avez plus que
cent dix-huit secondes pour les trois
épreuves qui vous sépare but
mademoiselle vous le savez le chrono
démarrera lorsque vous aurez fait passer
la première vue pour l'instant nous
sommes au départ concentrez-vous
calmement et maintenant nous sommes à
votre disposition
quant au oui oui oui
deuxio 12e ouïe ouïe troisième round oui
quatrième ouïe ouïe fine ensemble non
non oui
non non stop stop
eh bien c'est ce que j'espérais vous
avez rattrapé notre retard en effet vous
avez mis très peu de temps pour répondre
à cette question de peinture puisque
vous n'avez utilisé que 22 secondes et
vous n'avez presque retrouvé votre
moyenne 96 secondes vous reste
maintenant pour les deux dernières
épreuves et je vous le dis tout de suite
dans ces deux dernières épreuves y en a
également lu ne pouvait répondre très
rapidement je vous le dis dès maintenant
afin de vous rassurer un peu en cette
première semaine
mais avant d'aller plus loin il faut
encore vérifier vos résultats
nous allons les regarder voici votre
première réponse la demoiselle
c'est madame mère vous avez raison elle
figure dans le tableau du sacre ne
figurait pas par contre au sacre
historiquement mais david l'avait bien
représenté dans son tableau donc une
bonne réponse en deux vous avez dit
encore oui c'était berthier vous avez
raison il est bien dans le tableau du
sacre en 3 vous avez dit encore oui vous
avez toujours raison c'est hortense la
reine hortense et se trouvait bien un
tableau du sacre en cat bien sûr l'animé
pas d'hésitation sur le pape pie vii
vous aviez raison et là vous aviez vos
quatre bonnes réponses si vous aviez été
très sûr de vous je le signale c'est une
particularité notre jeu vous pouviez
arrêter là car le contrat a été rempli
mais vous avez préféré continuer nous
voyons maintenant napoléon et vous
continuez par une erreur car ce napoléon
là c'est celui de la remise des aigles
pas du tout celui du sac vous le savez
bien il tient la corogne ainsi au sud la
tête bien maintenant nous passons à la
faute au numéro 6 c'est murat mais n'est
pas dans le sacre vous avez raison c'est
encore une bonne réponse pour mons et
vous l'avez identifiés dans le sacré
vous avez raison il est dans le sacre
nous sommes pour l'instant si bonne
réponse vous avez dit non pour tyrone
main siglé dans le sacre bien sûr et
vous avez dit encore non je crois pour
ce petit enfant bien s'il figure dans le
sac c'est le fils de la reine hortense
le prince napoléon il était là vous avez
donc donné si je ne me trompe si bonnes
réponses
mademoiselle là quand même
on respire un peu la moyenne des
meilleurs si bonnes réponses cela
représente 300 francs qui viennent
s'ajouter aux 200 que vous aviez déjà
donc à votre gain total apparaît
maintenant la somme de 500 francs et
bien c'est un ami
talât mieux cette partie sur un meilleur
rythme on a passé le cap dramatique de
la deuxième question pour monsieur
castaing nous allons voir maintenant la
troisième à je vous signale pour cette
troisième épreuve
il s'agit maintenant de rome dans les
romans de roman assez classique
d'ailleurs est-ce que les romands sont
votre fort vous aimez la littérature
oui certainement c'est une de vos
parties fort je crois vous croyez que
vous êtes fou dingue c'est très bien
voix seulement 7 au troisième epr
eh bien oui pour cette troisième épreuve
nous allons parler de roman et nous
avons demandé très précisément à paul
via l'art de choisir dans sa
bibliothèque
9 monsieur quels critères ont dicté
votre choix s'il vous plaît des critères
très simple j'ai pris des romans
classiques et des romans contemporains
le ou les auteurs en sont célèbres je
suis persuadé que mademoiselle reynès va
trouver très rapidement et très bien
bien voulez-vous dire à mademoiselle
rennais ce monsieur viala ce que vous
attendez d'elle donc eh bien je voudrais
commencer leur haine s identifient
chacun de ses romans et je crois que la
forme du style aussi bien qu'eux mêmes
d'autres choses qui apparaissent dans
l'est dans la fin de ses romans même
puisque ce sont les dernières phrases
que nous allons lui donner lui
permettront de trouver puisque elle aime
la littérature et hellemmes le roman
donc je résume mademoiselle la règle du
jeu voici devant vous la liste des neuf
romans choisis par paul viallard lisez
les tranquilles mademoiselle olvia
larves à vous lire la dernière phrase de
chacun de vous avez bien compris c'est
le mot de la fin
n'est ce pas et vous devrez associé
cette fin elles vont bien entendu
alors vous regardez bien la liste tout
le monde peut jouer avec vous bien sûr
été les spectateurs jouent en même temps
que vous ils ont essayé de replacer
également ses fables dans les romans ce
sont des romans vous connaissez bien
mademoiselle il y en a certains oui dans
la dernière phrase des traits
caractéristiques d'autres plus bas qui
marque que moi là et moi enfin j'espère
les reconnaître même bien mais j'ai peur
je vous demanderai des que mademoiselle
reynès a dit je ne sais pas où a donné
une réponse d'enchaîner immédiatement
avec l'autre fin s'il vous plaît qui
suit nous allons pouvoir commencer
mademoiselle certainement monsieur paul
viola comme vous et ces deux âmes soeurs
trajet vol 93 a déjà répondu
l'autorité le ménager l'opinion publique
protège monsieur homais il vient de
recevoir la croix d'honneur madame
bovary et sa vie qui fut assez courtes
place des exemples de vertu il imite la
princesse de clèves
adieu ma chaire est digne amis j'éprouve
en ce moment que notre raison déjà 6
dans les liaisons dangereuses sans doute
des liaisons dangereuses elles farda ces
jouets célèbres avec minutie puis ayant
gagné la rue marchand au hasard je ne
sais pas c'est pas des hommes poussent
est une arme et les eskers routard nos
précédentes et les escrocs des hommes
poussent est une arme et noir vengeresse
dont la germination germinal vous pouvez
arrêter rendez vous dès maintenant
elle arrête là stop monsieur paul
villard je suis désolé que vous ayez été
aussi interrompue mais c'est le principe
même de notre jeunesse est terriblement
haletant et qui fait que mademoiselle a
très peur de perdre des secondes
elle était assez à l'aise dans cette
question puisque elle a identifié les
fans romands avant même que vous ayez
terminé ses fins je viens c'est assez
étonnant surtout pour le premier que
vous avez lu ou dès les deux premiers
mois la identifier immédiatement la fin
vous dire qu'elle est très
caractéristique très très
caractéristique
monsieur robert je sûr vous ne tiendrez
pas rigueur ne va pas du tout pas du
tout eh bien nous allons maintenant si
vous le voulez bien vérifier les
résultats voir s'il ya suffisamment de
bonnes réponses pour l'instant il vous
reste 48 secondes vous avez exactement
utilisé la moitié de votre temps pour
cette époque regardons donc vos
résultats en 1 vous avez dit
mademoiselle 93 oui et ces deux âmes
soeurs tragique s'envolèrent ensemble
l'ombre de lune mêlée à la lumière de
l'autre
la fin est très belle c'est
effectivement victory dont 93 une bonne
réponse
ensuite vous avez identifié madame
bovary avec monsieur o mais vous avez
bien raison c'est bien madame bovary
deux bonnes réponses
ensuite et bien et sa vie qui fut assez
courtes laisse des exemples virtuel
évitables c'est bien sûr la princesse de
clèves trois bonnes réponses
beauvais oise et ensuite à la vous avez
eu un petit retard vous hésitez vous
avez dit je ne sais pas si vous avez dit
les liaisons dangereuses vous aviez
raison il s'agit bien des liaisons
dangereuses
puis vous avez encore hésiter là vous
êtes revenu en arrière vous avez dit
thérèse desqueyroux c'est exact c'est
bien le roman de françois mauriac
ensuite eh bien là bien sûr c'était très
caractéristique du style de zola vous
avez dit germinal et là encore vous
aviez raison et je crois que vous êtes
arrêté là mademoiselle vous aurions en
soute la fin du grand meaulnes celle de
climat dans un mauroy et du rouge et
noir stada mais très très bonne réponse
puisqu'ils n'avaient pas une seule
erreur dans ses six premières réponses
bravo 300 francs pour ce
épreuve qui viennent s'ajouter aux 500
vous aviez déjà gagné ce qui fait 800
francs je voudrais poser une question à
paul viallard s'il est encore là bas
dans le décor et lui demander ce qu'il
pense de la rapidité extraordinaire avec
laquelle mademoiselle reynès répond à
nos questions
je trouve que mulroney s'est nourri de
classiques et je lui fais toutes mes
félicitations
merci bien merci d'être venu parmi nous
ce soir et nous espérons vous revoir une
prochaine émission de pas une seconde à
perdre
voici maintenant mademoiselle la
quatrième et dernière
[Musique]
comment faire pour aller en prison se
livrer au tapage nocturne
rocé son voisin mépriser les lois se
faire truand coupe-jarrets chevaliers de
la pince monseigneur irez-vous du même
coup en ces lieux des nommés par les
grands habitués le placard ce n'est
point une certitude une profession et
une seule conduite aisément à l'ombre le
métier d'écrivain l'histoire le prouve
l'écrivain va quatre fois plus en prison
que tout autre travailleur la politique
pour autant n'est pas toujours la cause
de l'incarcération et bien mademoiselle
voici neuf écrivains mis en prison pour
des raisons diverses et il faut bien le
dire il ya certains d'entre eux qui ont
été en prison uniquement pour des motifs
politiques d'autre voter pour des
raisons de droit commun d'ailleurs
disons le carrément de tête
ces neuf écrivains nous allons les
passer en revue si vous le voulez bien
il y a alfred de musset nerval aux dents
enjeux forts walter l'hydro paul louis
courier clients et beaumarchais
ils sont pour l'instant tous derrière
des grilles et bien alors voilà le jeu
il s'agit pour vous de libérer ceux qui
dans leur vie on était une fois en
prison pour des raisons politiques ils
ont pu aller d'ailleurs une autre fois
pour une autre saison mais nous libérons
que ces raisons là les autres mettant en
étant vraiment très très peu loin alors
vous avez vu vraiment c'est la faute
heures vous libérer ceux qui ont été une
fois dans leur vie
présente pour des raisons politiques ont
pris la question oui il vous reste 48
secondes je vous renseignerez
continuellement vous avez le temps donc
vous passez pas trop je vous renseignera
continuellement sur votre temps au fur
et à mesure de l'épreuve
vous êtes prête je libère ainsi vous
libérer en soulevant la petite grille
mais enlevez vous les aurez dans votre
main d'ailleurs ceux qui sont allés en
prison pour raisons politiques c'est ça
son plaisir considération d'autres
ferment d'autres peines de prison dans
leur vie mais ceux qui ont été au moins
une fois en prison pour raisons
politiques
voyez ce que je me dis bon eh bien alors
smoothies saint louis alors attention
chrono vous avez le temps et moselle 38
secondes vous arrêtez la top
vous avez beaucoup de gris il faut il
peut être par exemple vous avez mis 20
secondes vous aviez encore 28 secondes
mais il n'y a pas de raison de revenir
ce que vous avez fait d'ailleurs taille
rend disait lui-même que c'est le
premier geste qui le bon souvent c'est
la première inspiration qui est la bonne
eh bien j'espère pour vous que c'est le
cas ce soir et que vous avez triomphé
encore de cette dernière est quoi
mademoiselle nous allons vérifier vos
résultats nous les regarde premiers
résultats pour mu c'est bien vous avez
refusé de libérer vous l'avez laissée en
prison disent que nous sommes bien
d'accord
et vous avez raison car il devait rester
en prison d'où il avait été condamné
pour ne pas voir monter la garde
quand les gardes nationales géant nerval
vous avez refusé de libérer il fallait
le libérer car il a été en reste
il a été en prison également pour
raisons politiques proudhon vous l'avait
libéré et vous avez raison mademoiselle
tout à fait juste c'était une bonne
réponse vous avez libéré également
rochefort bien sûr une bonne réponse
vous avez libéré voltaire encore une
bonne réponse ça se passe très bien pour
vous vous avez libéré diderot encore une
bonne réponse est exacte
vous avez libéré pelouse doit y être une
petite hésitation et bien c'était juste
la demoiselle vous n'avez pas libéré
villon ça c'est évident qu'à vous savez
qu'il est deux fois en prison pour vol
et peaux mortes
et enfin vous avez libéré bon marché
c'est parfaitement exact vous aviez tout
à fait raison donc une excellente une
remarquable dernière épreuve
8 réponses justes sur les neuf possibles
400 francs au total
et finalement vous terminer cette
première semaine la demoiselle en ayant
à votre gain total 1200 voilà et bien
dites moi vous avez une grosse émotion à
la première pour la musique pour vous ce
n'est pas votre fort et bien non surtout
liszt et chopin que je ne connais pas
très bien et je peux je ne connaissais
pas très bien pour d'eau dans les
éliminatoires que nous avons fait il y
avait une partie sonore rappelez vous en
vous aviez été beaucoup plus brillant
oui la fin non remember me et bien bravo
mademoiselle vous passer le cap de cette
première semaine nous vous retrouverons
donc en deuxième semaine la semaine
prochaine vous aurez 5 répond juste sur
neuf à nous donner mais là vous pourrez
faire appel à des supporters et puis
d'autre part le gain sera plus important
100 francs par raiponce dire le double
d'aujourd'hui
et bien maintenant les shazam il est
temps de vous expliquer en quoi consiste
le supporter
oui vous venez de voir monsieur castaing
mais lui ne peut plus supporter puisque
est éliminé soulève un modèle rennaise
pour cette demoiselle qui restent seuls
en course pour l'instant bien vous avez
peut-être de la sympathie vous désirez
peut-être devenir son supporter alors
pour cela c'est extrêmement simple vous
nous envoyer une carte postale en
précisant votre nom votre adresse et
votre numéro de téléphone qui doit
obligatoirement pouvoir être appelé
depuis paris par l'automatique cas il
faut aller très vite ne pouvons pas
faire autrement nous en excusons auprès
de ceux qui ne possèdent pas encore le
match et puis sur cette carte postale
bien sûr vous indiquer la spécialité
pour laquelle vous sentez le plus fort
par exemple en art céleste coupe
beaucoup de choses vous pouvez nous
écrire je suis fort sur les potes 19e
siècle ou encore d'une manière plus
étroite
je suis fort sur mu c'est sûr lamartine
sur victor hugo peu importe la part
pour laquelle vous sentez bien armés
voilà ça c'est ce qui nous nous
intéresse toutes ses cartes ici sont
classés par catégorie seront mises à
partir de la seconde semaine à la
disposition des modèles reynès et par
quatre fois au cours des quatre semaines
lui reste à affronter
eh bien elle aura le droit de faire
appel à un supporter c'est à dire
qu'avant de voir les résultats
elle pourra demander supporters et vous
depuis votre domicile devant votre
téléviseur eh bien vous pourrez
rattraper la candidate vous pourrez
rectifier ses erreurs si vous croyez
qu'elle en a fait ou confirmés bien
entendu les réponses qui leur a bien
donné
voilà vous avez compris le système c'est
extrêmement simple et vous serez
intéressé à 5% ce qui n'est pas
négligeable du gain final de la
candidate bien sûr gagne voilà j'ai tout
dit ah si une dernière précision qui me
semble indispensable il faut envoyer
votre carte postale a pas une seconde à
perdre maison de l'eau et rtf 116 avenue
du président-kennedy paris 16ème je
deviens pas une seconde à perdre mais on
nourrir tf 116 avenue du
président-kennedy paris 16e voilà nous
verrons bien entendu à nouveau
concurrent la semaine prochaine qui lui
sera en première semaine et nous
suivrons demoiselle reynès en seconde
semaine
au revoir à semaine prochaine
[Musique]